all right para the questions from the
internets gustavo asks why do you think
bill o'reilly interview with obama was
unpatriotic you've insulted bush way
worse than a right now you know what I'm
so glad this guy asked us cuz I heard
O'Reilly and shot Joe Scarborough asked
us you've insulted Bush way worse than
O'Reilly insulted Obama yes but not to
his face that's the difference people
are so [ __ ] stupid I mean yes you're
right I called Bush a [ __ ] and every
other thing but if I went to the White
House and was sitting in the Oval Office
talking to Bush I would not talk to him
that way because I would have respect
for the office and when you talk to the
president even if you don't agree with
them and don't like him you let him
finish a sentence everyone in the world
everyone in the world
obeys this rule except Bill O'Reilly
other heads of state John McCain it
doesn't matter everyone treats the
president differently than you treat a
guy at the corner bar but it's not like
but it's not like any of us principally
the president didn't know that before he
agreed to sit down with Bill O'Reilly if
I'm a do in the first place right well
because he wanted to reach people why
did you know no same reason he goes on
you know whenever shows he goes on do
you think
thank you
thank you man who can only speak a dick
joke do you think it's time for a
constitutional convention cabin yes
absolutely no I have no idea what I do I
mean Thomas Jefferson said every 20
years you kind of have to a revolution
is that not a constant well he said you
have to you know refresh the blood of
people but do you want to change the
constitution oh well I'd like to get rid
of corporate personhood I would be like
number one we could relook at the Second
Amendment since when they wrote it it
was about muskets the Senate could go my
god I guess unfortunately those that if
you had a constitutional convention
right now given the current political
makeup the country you would end up with
a slightly different result than the one
that you would like to see right cap on
spending all those great kind of things
I'd like any really good I'd like equal
access to a high quality education for
every child in America
[Applause]
this one is for you I think freshy says
many of CNBC's editorial rants sound
like something one would hear on fox
news why is that
mmm well they disagree with the premise
actually I don't think you'd hear a lot
of rants on CNBC they're totally similar
to Fox News I think we're actually very
different the teabagger movement really
started on CNBC with that Rick's
Antonelli rant Rick Santelli yes he did
start it there give him credit for
starting the tea party movement you like
the tea I like the message of fiscal
restraint absolutely and I would say
that actually what I see on other
networks is a lot more talk about social
issues which I think what was so
successful a tea party Tea Party
movement was focusing on fiscal issues
and getting rid of the Socialists oh
they stopped eating all of that agree
yeah I agree with you 100% but at least
we can have that conversation now I
think for the first time in a long time
and you know the nation we don't define
ourselves by abortion and gay rights why
do we define our parties that way
well it's interesting cos isn't the
question originally about CNBC yes about
the tea party absolutely fine
financially I mean they're talking about
the 10 commandments on the front of the
no but but I mean just financially you
know I mean your show powerless yeah I
mean we definitely doesn't sound like
it's inviting in the poor we don't even
economic Liberty and free market
capitalism as the bethe best path to
prosperity capitalism is what made this
country great and we embrace it and I
love it I don't think where anyone
disagrees with that I don't think any
party in this country is anti-capitalist
ok so then I fundamentally disagree
there with the premise that we sound
like other networks that want to focus
you don't think alike 10 commandments on
you don't think Obama's a socialist do
you no but he's extremely liberal he's
the most liberal president with what on
what liberal about this man I am so
clueless about where you get this that
makes two of us I mean
what tell me what is so what tell me why
he is so liberal because he's a
government can solve so many problems
that it can't be health care is that we
were talking but health care you I mean
we do know that the status quo of health
care was not acceptable on the
absolutely not would just explode the
debt which is what you care about more
than things look the chart went I mean
under Clinton when they tried to solve
but it was like eight percent yeah and
then it got up to about twice that now
like 16 percent half to get up to like
yes thirty percent so something had to
be done yes that's why he attacked it
first any any most companies around the
country were telling Barack Obama for
all 2007-2008 that he needed to do
something to solve this problem for them
because their costs were spiraling out
of control the problem is the
conversation starts in the wrong place
it's should employers provide health
care or should the government provide
health care and the answer is neither we
buy our own car insurance we buy our own
life insurance we should all buy my own
car insurance because the government
forces us to buy a car yeah well I
disagree we had to what about the 40 50
60 million people who can't afford to
buy health insurance that's sort of what
this is about if the government weren't
so involved it would be cheaper and far
more affordable it's really it's the
government that's jacking up the prices
isn't it more the insurance companies
[Applause]
hospitals that are for-profit no I think
you should I think you should ask Matt
how well untrammeled deregulation worked
in the financial market and then tell us
how would apply in the healthcare market
how about that and that's absolutely
true I mean look at the in the in the
health insurance industry I went I
visited a hospital in Bayonne New Jersey
where it's 50% of their administrative
staff is devoted to chasing down claims
from insurance companies how can that
possibly be efficient that doesn't make
any sense all these different insurance
companies there has to be some kind of
regulation that standardizes this
process and makes it sensible just in
general I mean the fact that we spend
like half of what we spend twice rather
what they spend in France and they get a
better result well and almost every
other modern industrialized Western
democracy has some sort of Medicare for
all food why are they all talking on it
they are their budgets are what do you
think all of them yes really they're all
choking for everybody's trying to cut it
back on on the services that they
provide remedies refined to cut back on
the service
cut when you look at their health care
spending and on their spending for yeah
absolutely
absolutely as a percentage of the
national per capita income it's much
much income it's smaller but when it
comes to their budgets they're spending
bigger percentages I don't think that's
true actually I think we actually spend
a much greater percentage of our GDP yes
of our federal budget no jikan
all right let's eat some chicken
audience thank you
you